this IMF forecasts carries a sobering
message the economic pain of Kobe Denine
team will be deep and protracted and
nowhere will be spared for the first
time every region of the world will face
recession simultaneously
this chart shows forecast growth with
the baseline in 2019 moving through to
2021 global growth is projected to fall
by 4.9 percent this year the largest
contraction since the Great Depression a
consequence of what the IMF calls the
great lockdown developing economies face
a lower contraction of 3% though the
consequences of the recession for the
poorest countries are severe advanced
economies including Europe and the US of
forecast are contract by 8 percent China
where the virus began and which knocked
down early and was back in business by
April will actually grow by when 1
percent now you can see these economies
will recover over the course of 2021 the
forecast is for global growth of 5
percent and that would deliver not a
rapid v-shaped recovery but a slower
swoosh shape so how do we compare the
European countries worst affected by
coronavirus will suffer the deepest
recessions Italy and Spain will contract
by 12.8% in France by 12 and a half
percent the UK faces a 10 point 2
percent decline the worst fall in GDP in
300 years and worse than the u.s. at 8
percent and Germany which will shrink by
7.8 percent now all these countries are
forecast to recover next year by between
4 & 7 percent but that will still leave
the UK with a smaller economy even by
the end of 2021 the level of GDP in the
UK will be lower than the pre-crisis
levels this is a prolonged hit and as we
know there are sectors that are getting
hit in this crisis are the ones that
employ low-skilled workers they also
tend to be more labor intensive and so
the effect on employment can be
substantial the IMF warns that the
looming recession will hit the poorest
in every nation hardest to soften the
blow it's calling for international
collaboration to support potential
vaccine production economic resilience
and an acceleration of climate change
programs
but so far in this outbreak genuine
cooperation has been in short supply